hey this is presh talwalkar
on a table are nine face up cards
each card displays a different number
from the list
two four eight sixteen thirty two sixty
four one twenty eight two fifty six and
five hundred twelve
alice and bob play a game where they
alternately take turns
each picks a single card on a turn and
alice goes first
once a card is chosen it cannot be
selected again
the game ends when someone wins or all
the cards have been selected
the winner is the first person to
collect a set of three cards with a
product of thirty two thousand seven
hundred and sixty eight
for example in the game just illustrated
alice collects the cards 416 and 512
which have a product of 32 768 so alice
wins that game
but there could be other games in which
bob selects a set of three cards that
have a product of 32
768.
in that case bob would be the winner
but there could also be games in which
alice gets a set of cards and bob gets a
set of cards but neither have collected
a set in which there are three cards
that have a product of 32
768.
in that case the game ends in a draw
the problem is if both play optimally
does either player have a winning
strategy
or does the game always end in a draw
and how should you play this game
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
the game seems like it's impossible to
solve
how can you keep track of all the
possible ways that they can pick numbers
and how can a person know if a set of
three numbers even has a product of
32768
amazingly the game has a simple solution
and you probably already know how to
solve it
if you've been watching my videos long
enough you already might know the trick
so we'll start out with the simple game
of tic-tac-toe
imagine that alice plays x on this three
by three grid and bob plays o
they take turns hoping to be the first
to make three in a row
now as you
know if both play optimally each can
block the other perfectly so that
neither player can make three in a row
resulting in a draw game
now let's consider a new game
we'll first write the numbers 1 through
9 in the grid to make a magic square
we'll have each row column and diagonal
have a sum of 15.
that is this row this row and this row
each row has a sum of 15.
each column has a sum of 15
and each diagonal has a sum of 15.
furthermore this arrangement is unique
up to rotation and reflection so there's
no other three by three magic square
with the numbers one through nine and
the only triplets with the sum of 15 are
in the rows columns and diagonals
so now consider a game alice and bob
takes turns selecting cards and the
first person to have three cards with
the sum of 15 wins
let's mark alice's cards with an x and
bob's cards with an
o now after the second move bob has to
block alice's three in a row by picking
nine
now alice has to block the three in a
row by picking one
bob plays somewhere and then alice has
to block three in a row by picking three
then bob has to block
and then the game ends in a draw
as you can see the strategy to this game
is just like tic-tac-toe
if played optimally by both the game is
sure to end in a draw you simply pick
numbers
in which you would pick the same spot in
tic-tac-toe
so how does this relate to the race to
32
768
what we'll do is we'll do a
transformation to each number
for each number x in this magic square
we'll replace it with the new number 2
to the power of x so the number 4
becomes 2 to the power of 4 which is 16.
9 becomes 2 to the power of 9 which is
512.
we'll replace each entry in this magic
square with 2 to the power of that entry
what we have now is a multiplicative
magic square
each row column and diagonal has the
product equal to 2 to the power of 15
which is 32
768.
so now we analyze the race to 32
768.
if we mark alice's choices as x's
and bob's choices as os then the game
has the same strategy as tic-tac-toe
after a few moves we know where alice
has to go to block bob from making three
numbers who have a product of 32 768.
furthermore bob knows where he has to
pick in order to block alice's three in
a row
so if both play optimally the game is
just like tic tac toe and it should end
in a draw
not only should it end in a draw but
there is a simple way that each player
can select cards to block the other
player
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description